He's in trouble it's not like your dead
husband can die twice oh full of surprises
i'm fine
why would you think that
i think the few unsavory characters settling
in the neighborhood are you here to help us
i think something's wrong here there's no need
to get dramatic did you really not see what
i saw she recast pietro if you're not watching
Wandavision you're missing out marvel is finally back
Am I dead? No!
Welcome back everyone this is going to
be my Wandavision episode 6 trailer video
there's obviously so much stuff going on so
many big twists so we'll break it all down
we did not see that coming if you're new to the
channel i'm doing videos for all the episodes
be sure to subscribe to get them we're doing
a disney plus giveaway for memberships too
all you have to do to enter is be a subscriber
and leave all your theories about the big twists
in the last episode on the video so obviously
careful for spoilers if you have not seen last
week's episode yet but because they break all
the footage from across the episode up in the
trailer the scenes are edited out of order in
this trailer so it seems like after evan peters
quicksilver shows up and wanda stops freaking out
it just accepts him as her pietro even though she
knows something isn't quite right and claims she
had nothing to do with it she introduces vision
he chills out a little bit because right before he
rung the doorbell they were almost coming to blows
and he has that line of dialogue where he says
who's the popsicle everybody wondering if that
means that he knows that vision is dead secretly
which is a big twist on top of another big twist
but there's the audio in the trailer where we
hear him mocking scarlet witch saying it's not
like your dead husband can die twice so it seems
like that confirms that he knows that vision is
dead somehow this is all playing out during the
90s halloween episode that's basically the big
theme of the episode you can make as many full
house references as you want because that was a
90s sitcom and quicksilver here evan peters
quicksilver is kind of like the uncle jesse
character showing up in his leather jacket also
on top of that we're still wondering what the big
twist is behind his character showing up seemingly
from the multiverse because he's the fox x-men
version of quicksilver there were a lot of
people that were pointing to the descriptive
audio in the episode so there's subtitles and then
there's descriptive audio for the hard of hearing
the official descriptive audio claims that this
is quicksilver from the x-men movies here i'll
play the clip in westview wanda stares
at the version of pietro from the x-men
so it's not clear if they want us to just
take that at face value like oh no this is
full multiverse and that's what the twist is meant
to be or there's something else going on with this
character because when he is mocking scarlet witch
he sounds like he's being a huge dick why would
he do that if there weren't some other twists
behind his character why would he be so mean like
that and here's another big question about his
character how does quicksilver from the fox marvel
x-men universe know about something that happened
in an alternate universe he was not around for
vision's death in avengers infinity war even the
real phrow the original quicksilver wasn't around
for that and wouldn't know that vision died so
even if aaron taylor johnson had been the one to
ring that doorbell he should not know that vision
is really dead so i think that just implies that
there's some bigger twist at play with his
character showing up like this and knowing
what he knows i said it during my episode 5 video
the way he performs those lines like hey baby bro
give me a hug doesn't sound like his x-men version
of the character so it sounds like he's performing
the character either differently because of the
episode or because he's another character just
pretending to be quicksilver from the fox marvel
x-men films if this were any other marvel tv show
we could take it a little closer to face value
like when falcon and winter soldier episodes
start that'll be a more straight-up marvel
adventure series like you would expect it to
be like captain america winter soldier twist but
not the crazy level of twist that we just got in
last week's episode people seemingly crossing the
multiverse or playing with our perceptions making
us think that people crossed the multiverse you
have to remember that a lot of what's happening
in the episode a lot of these big twists are all
based on scarlet witch's reality warping powers
the cosmic radiation that she's manipulating the
same energy as the infinity stones so a lot of
this is just flowing from her imagination
so they kind of did the same thing during
the legion tv show where you're never quite sure
what's going on because you're viewing everything
from the perspective of a mentally ill character
in wanda's mental state is slowly deteriorating
but then it seems like what happens is he just
crashes at their place overnight like vision
said every time they switch to another day she
changes everything so then during the night when
they wake up again she changes everything to the
1990s and it becomes the big halloween episode
there was a casting scene for billy and tommy last
year that got out where they talked to each other
about waking their uncle up who was sleeping on
the couch and at the time i assumed that that
meant the quicksilver was going to be on the show
because vision does not have any siblings but at
the time obviously we weren't thinking about them
doing the evan peters quicksilver from the x-men
movies that's just the icing on the cake like
kevin feige is saying you want some quicksilver
to come back hold my beer we'll do you one better
there's probably a whole bunch of other stuff that
happens before the halloween trick or treating
starts like we see in all the footage like them
paying off the scene of monica rambo using that
craft to get back inside the barrier remember
if she says she knew someone there were people
claiming that they sussed out in the transcript
for the episode that monica rambo was talking to
a female character i don't know if that's true
but that would change some of the theories about
who she's referring to hopefully they'll clarify
in a future episode because i would love for that
character to be the blue marvel he's an engineer
but they might wait to introduce him to the
captain marvel sequels or some other marvel movie
and i'd love for it to be a fantastic four
character but kevin feige said that they haven't
cast any of those fantastic four characters yet
this footage of her trying to break back in could
also be from a different episode because remember
this is all playing out during the span of a
single week of the year like it's all happening
in a very short time span but halloween starts you
get that scene of her and vision walking out in
their classic comic book costumes i can't wait to
see that it's going to be so hilarious and amazing
at the same time i'm also hoping that that means
that evan peters wears a halloween version of
the classic x-men quicksilver costume the funny
thing about this too is that elizabeth olsen also
said that they had to fight to get these halloween
comic book costumes on the show they originally
weren't planning on doing this but for those of
you wondering why they haven't done a more comic
book accurate scarlet witch costume in the mcu
before they've actually tried to do it all the way
back since her debut during avengers age of ultron
not counting the captain america winter soldier
post credit scene this is a lot of concept art for
what her look was going to be during avengers age
of ultron and then when the russo brothers sort of
took over the character in captain america civil
war in avengers infinity war avengers end game
there's more concept art for them trying to
do the special head piece so they've at least
attempted to do it before hopefully we'll see a
more modern version of that costume maybe during
doctor strange 2 multiverse of madness as they
start trick-or-treating it seems like vision
just starts to see weird stuff happening again and
it's not clear if wanda has wiped his memory again
overnight doing her rewind to reset him again but
however he comes to it he encounters agnes wearing
her wicked witch of the west costume i know just
more clues that there's something weird going on
with our character more agatha harkness easter
eggs in the comics agatha harkness was a witch
who was burned at the stake during the salem witch
trials but however their conversation goes it
seems like she asks him really like are you part
of the avengers are you here to rescue us begging
him for help if that's what causes him to change
back to his regular avengers costume he floats up
into the air to survey the town then there's that
footage of him trying to break through the barrier
of westview to talk to the sword agents and monica
rambeau but then for whatever reason it seems
like he gets yanked back in the barrier by someone
either a scarlet witch or someone else because you
also have that audio of billy and tommy freaking
out talking to scarlet witch saying that vision is
in trouble she needs to help him so it's not clear
what's happening to vision when that's going on
that could be when he's outside the barrier or it
could be some other encounter that he has during
the episode also answering the big question of
what happens to vision when he goes outside the
barrier because right now monica rambeau in that
jump rope with the cable that turned into the
jump rope are the only things that we've seen
make it back outside the barrier they kind of
tried to explain that like monica rambeau's 70s
costume was basically just a re-imagined retuned
version of her original sword costume that's why
it was 80 percent kevlar scarlet witch rewrote the
reality of her regular modern day costume into
a 60s costume so does that also mean that she
rewrote the reality of vision to make him
alive again because she sees him briefly and
he's walking around looking dead like weekend
at bernie style during episode 3 and episode 4.
it seems like he's able to speak when he gets
outside the barrier though for at least a little
while so whatever's happening it does seem like
he's capable of at least existing for a hot second
when he's outside the barrier a lot of people
theorizing that there'll be some twist that
will prevent him from existing or continuing
to exist after Wandavision is over like scarlet
witch will have to say goodbye to him or he'll
have to sacrifice himself somehow they had that
whole scene during episode 5 about her giving the
kids the lesson about not running from their pain
because sparky the dog had died and she didn't
want to bring him back like no we can't we can't
be doing stuff like that but she literally just
did that with vision so part of the series is her
taking her own medicine learning to get over
visions death finally there's a lot of other
footage in the trailer too that i know is from
other future episodes like the modern family
footage of her making the joke about having a
case of the mondays that's probably from episode
7 maybe beyond that when they hit the 2000s era
of sitcoms then we see this footage now we can say
this is a scene of her actually breaking into the
sword headquarters on earth to steal vision's body
because it looks exactly like the cam version
of the footage they played during episode 5.
so either that's in next week's episode or later
episodes and we just see it play out in the moment
yes i do have more theories about what's going
on with tyler heyward now because it seems like
during that five year time jump they had vision's
body hooked up to all these systems like they were
trying to use his body to develop more weapons
and ai as part of that new modus operandi sentient
weapons observation and response department he
had that big conversation with monica rambeau
about how their agency was all about sentient
weapons now and that's exactly what vision is
she had that weird look on her face like she
thought that it was a really ominous thing
so it seems like whatever they were doing with
vision is connected to that and they were very
clear during the episode when they were talking
about vision's living will he didn't want to be
brought back because he didn't want to be used
as a weapon so it sounds like tyler heyward was
actually trying to use vision as a weapon that
doesn't absolutely confirm that he's a skrull or
there's some other big twist right now he's still
just kind of a douche but he's becoming more of an
antagonist on the series just like scarlet wishes
that's the whole idea so it's possible that there
is some other big twist behind his character
and they wind up having to take him down at
some point too or he gets his comeuppance by the
finale i know a lot of people are also wondering
if monica rambeau has her comic book photon powers
now because of the weird ekg scan scene there were
all those weird readings on her medical charts
those light blooms so people were like does this
mean that she has her powers now it's totally
possible that this is the beginning of that and
they'll just continue to develop that throughout
the rest of the episodes and then pay it off in a
much bigger way during the captain marvel 2 movie
monica rambeau is also probably going to show up
on that nick fury avengers secret invasion series
because it'll probably involve some sword stuff
as well they did say that the Wandavision episodes
would give you an idea for monica rambeau's future
in the marvel cinematic universe and i think that
was a reference to her becoming a version of the
photon character so i do think that we'll see them
pay that off during the rest of these episodes
and remember a couple weeks ago there was all this
talk about elizabeth olsen being really excited
for a special cameo scene on the series and people
were making luke skywalker mandalorian references
i think that that secret cameo that they were
talking about is not the evan peters quicksilver
twist i think it'll be somebody else probably and
it'll be closer to the finale this is obviously a
big twist it's really cool to see him on the show
but it's happening so early in the episodes that
it feels like there's going to be an even bigger
twist later on closer to the finale like that's
where you put the biggest twist right in the
finale everyone post all your theories about
what's going on with quicksilver and what's going
on with tyler heyward and monica rambeau and her
powers in the comments below my full episode 6
video will post friday and tomorrow is the super
bowl so there's supposed to be a couple marvel
trailers during the super bowl i'll do videos for
all those whatever it is they wind up dropping
maybe falcon winter soldier trailer maybe a new
loki trailer maybe a new black widow trailer maybe
something for the other movies we'll find out
make sure you have alerts enabled for my
channel so you don't miss any of those videos
and i'll name a giveaway winner when i post that
first super bowl trailer video everyone click here
for my full Wandavision episode 5 video and click
here for my Wandavision fantastic four easter eggs
video thank you so much for watching everyone
stay safe and i'll see you in the next video!